The Joe Rogan Experience that was in my
opinion one of the most technical and
one of like the the finest performances
in that division that 135 pound division
to have a guy like you and Marlon go
after it like that that was a [__]
great fight thank you really great fight
and you're you're like on top of it
right now man it's really exciting to
watch yeah um I'm getting pretty good
you know yeah for real like I've really
been
just plugging up some holes like
figuring some some stuff out I feel like
uh I'm at the part in the martial arts
Journey where I've gotten really good at
being a really good learner like I can
learn super fast and super efficiently
now
um and it's like big time paying off
like not only that but I also the space
I was in before that Cheeto fight was uh
unlike one that I feel like I've ever
been in in my life how so
you know uh have you read like a decent
amount of sports psych books yes where
they'll sometimes talk about how you're
almost having this out of Body
Experience where you're hat where you're
almost like uh floating above the court
or the field or whatever it was almost
like that except I wouldn't use the word
like floating above but
I got to a space
in that fight where
um
I felt like all of the thoughts and all
of the distracting things that sometimes
happen in a fight
were completely ignored and this like
higher being better version like best no
thinker just actor was running the show
like it's almost like I was watching the
thing happen while I was in the fight
and there would be bits of me hopping in
and being like hey throw this
combination hey take a little bit more
of a risk okay do this and then that
would get completely just watched and
this whoever was fighting that night
that didn't even feel like me was the
person that was fighting it was [__]
cool man wow it was cool dude it was
like
you know
like a psychedelic experience feeling
type of thing it was cool what do you
attribute that to how did you get to
that mindset it's a lot of uh
you know messing stuff up like I
remember the last time I was on was
right after I had beaten Frankie and uh
I was
in it's just a bunch of different parts
of the journey and and uh in that part
of the journey I was really in this
space where if I could make myself more
war if I could make myself more Angry if
I could make make myself be up here I
would have success that kind of stopped
working a little bit after uh
like around the TJ fight and then kind
of during the yawn fight and then
definitely I've tried to be that guy
against song and it was like too much of
a distracting feeling
where now my mindset's going into the
last fight because it was such like a
distracting feeling just feeling like I
have to get myself to a point of anger
or upness before a fight where
it just be became distracting where it
was helpful before it became distracting
in that song Fight I bailed on that and
I just tried to be as Mindful and as
present as I possibly could
um for like and I know that those are
like kind of corny words now but uh
there is some real substance to them uh
when they're like really done well and I
would say maybe about six weeks before
the fight I I had this moment where I
was sitting on the couch because I put a
lot of pressure on myself and I I uh I
want to be a World Champ real bad
um
where I was to the point where I wasn't
enjoying any part of the camp any part
of the experience of fighting or
anything
and I was sitting on the couch and I
just like I I think I was crying a
little bit and I was like I can't
[__] do this for the next five years
of my life you know like I can't do this
for the rest of my career and I was like
well what's got to change and I was like
I Gotta Lose I gotta take this pressure
off of me and I gotta start enjoying
every day a lot more than I am right now
and from that like six weeks before the
fight I started doing that and I really
think that that carried into the fight
and it made me be
a lot less tense a lot less tight and it
made me be able to fight with just like
a completely free way of being
wow and is this something that you had
previously thought that you could get to
that space or wanted to get to that
space or is this something that you kind
of experimented along the way and found
this path
I'm a self-learner uh and and I think
that uh
I think that there's ways of being in
life that like you just kind of have to
be at certain times like when you're a
young kid like you have to be like going
and hitting it hard like you have to
remember all of the hundreds of
thousands of people on the other half of
the world that are trying to accomplish
the same goal as you and you have to be
a little bit in my opinion you have to
be a little bit on the neurotic side of
like am I doing every single thing
correct am I doing uh am I putting the
right amount of pressure on me that
that's totally a part of the journey but
I'm kind of more on the part of the
journey where I've matured a lot as a
fighter I've matured a lot as a person
I'm getting married this year like I'm a
little bit older we're looking at kids
probably in the next couple years and so
I had to start thinking like what's
sustainable like what's like a
sustainable way to continue doing what I
love but also becoming like a more
mature adult
um
and that's just part of the journey that
I'm in right now and uh I don't think
that anything was wrong with the way
that I was doing before but
it just is like a moving Target all the
time so it's like you're just finding
new ways to approach it and then
realizing this weighs better than the
other way even though the other way was
effective this is even more effective so
you're constantly trying to tweak it
yeah and and I think that uh
everything kind of has its purpose like
uh in those times where I would I was
really embracing this like War mentality
this like very like
bloodthirsty vicious type of fighter
that I was trying to be when I would go
into the cage that totally had its place
because I had to experience what I've
what I thought that had to feel like in
order for me to be the best martial
artist that I can because I do feel like
I've pointed all of my energy in my life
and my mind and my spirit and everything
towards the direction of being the best
martial artist that I can be and so
going through that had its purpose being
like I I had to figure out what it was
like for me to be
like a vicious killer you know because
in society that's like not cool you know
so like almost like uh the Shadow Self
or whatever uh is like the subconscious
term for it
um I had to like experience that I
experienced it I figured out that it was
no longer serving me it was being
distracting so what do I need to do now
now it's like okay you figured that part
out you can be that guy whenever you
want to be that guy but now we're being
present now we're enjoying it and you
don't really need to be that guy until
you walk into the cage and even when you
do walk into the cage you don't need to
be this like really dramatic super
emphasized like vicious guy like be that
guy but
you don't have to overdo it and and when
you're learning something I almost feel
like you have to completely overdo it in
order to learn like where that cut off
is like even in technique like
if you could do a arm bar
and win every single time with an arm
bar why would you ever stop doing arm
plays right it'd be stupid so like you
figure out how to like do something way
overdo it figure out where the cutoff is
and be like ah okay I can't do it in
like those situations you pull back you
figure out what situations you need to
do it in and then you move forward what
was this what happened I lost can you
hear me
my uh headphones cut out
hold on
check check check check check
something happened over here Jamie I
don't know what's going on but I lost
the uh headphones
we'll be right back folks sorry about
that no that's okay so
so where where were we at um so what was
it about the other way you were
approaching it where you know last time
you were here you would just Embrace
this idea that you went in there with
the intention to [__] people up
what was distracting about that it's
it's like a it's like a hot Burning
Flame you know like uh I I feel like
it's I can only hold on to it for so
long like I can't really uh
like it's a lot of energy to be that up
and so when I would be in the back
getting warmed up because you kind of
you don't know exactly when you're gonna
walk so I try to be ready you know like
20 minutes before
it's been like 30 40 minutes warming up
trying to be that guy and then for 20
minutes trying to sustain that guy and
that's like a long time to be that up
you know so even in the in this fight uh
because there's no preparing for that
last hour before you go walk like I
don't care what type of guy you are or
how Zen you can be or how confident you
are that that last hour before a fight
like your mind's gonna [__] with you a
lot and it's gonna go to you thinking
that you're the god of the universe to
you thinking that like you're about to
go get slaughtered and uh
in the back
before
if I started to feel like I was you know
having those like impulsive thoughts of
like fear or you're about to go get
slaughtered I try to just cover that
[__] up real quick by getting like real
pissed
um and that's like a lot of energy to do
so before the Cheeto fight I was super
proud of the way that I was able to
handle those feelings because those
feelings are like real as hell when
you're in the back
and how do you handle them well I just
watched them man like uh I just realized
like ah okay like I'm having I'm having
the sense of fear in me and I would just
kind of sit there and be like okay well
I'm not really fighting right now so
just let the fear be there right now
your job is to get warmed up and so I
just took it okay right now I'm getting
warmed up okay they said 10 more minutes
till we walk
okay I'm having the sense of fear still
that's okay I'm still in the back and
then step by step by step okay I'm I'm
walking out now cool
okay looking across from them okay touch
gloves now we're fighting it's literally
it sounds super [__] simple but it's
just step by step by step man just like
okay I'm having that sense I'll just
watch that and not really ignore I mean
you acknowledge it but you don't I
didn't I don't try to cover it up or I
don't try to like be someone else I just
kind of watch it as if it was just
someone else it happened into someone
else and then just move on it doesn't
sound super simple at all but not to me
at least it's I know what you're saying
and that feeling has got to be like
riding a wild wave like you just gotta
maintain your balance and to watch you
go into that fight
what was so impressive
um besides the fact that you're fighting
a world-class guy in Marlon Vera and you
you were controlling the action was the
overwhelming like the amount of
information you were throwing at him you
were constantly changing levels
constantly threatening takedowns
constantly switching stances and
everything was you know there's Fighters
kind of sometimes they'll fall into a
pattern and you can kind of predict that
pattern there was no pattern with you it
was all over the place and it was so
overwhelming when I was watching I was
like Jesus Christ like this is so high
level and I don't I mean for like a
casual
don't know if they're seeing that but
for someone who watches a lot of fights
and has been around martial arts you
know my whole life when I was watching I
was like this is about as high level as
it gets thank you like you were mixing
[__] up so well like the way you were
choosing your attacks whether it was the
low kick or whether it was punches and
the switch stance to punches the the the
shot it was amazing man it was really
[__] good it was really fun to watch
because it wasn't just that you were
doing that but you were doing that for
five [__] rounds like you never
varied you never slowed down there was
never like breathers it was just a
full-on assault of all of his reactions
and all of his uh his you know ability
to read you it was like attack bang hit
there okay trying to settle boom this
coming in oh now there's a shot it was
like there was no there was no breaks
yeah it was pretty awesome man like
pretty [__] wild yeah it was pretty
wild I think that that's always going to
be one of my stronger points is that I
can make decisions a lot faster than
other people
um I I honestly think that that's what
makes good people from great people
because good people can do they can make
the right decisions and continue to make
them continue to make them continue to
make them but uh at some point the
person that's better at doing those
things is going to surpass that person
eventually it might not happen early you
know like it could take some time and
against some of the best guys in the
world it's going to take some time but
eventually your processing speed will
outpower theirs you know and I think
that I do that really really well I
think that
um my training has a lot to do with that
too what is different about your
training
um so all of the conditioning that I do
or almost like the the conditioning
parts that I take really seriously
um are the sparring days I used to like
hit mitts real hard and I still do like
a strength and conditioning workout once
a week
that's like you know 30 seconds 30
seconds 30 seconds minute rest you know
and stuff like that but
um there's no getting tired like there
is getting tired and sparring so I'll do
if I I usually do 10 week camps the
first week I just knocked the rust off
you know and then I do two seven weeks
or two seven round weeks so we Spar
Tuesday Fridays I do seven rounds those
days and then the next two weeks I do
eight rounds both of those days and then
I'll do like six and then the rest of
them five because I want to get used to
five but in those seven round weeks and
those eight round weeks those are hard
as [__] man like I get like I try to get
so tired where I'm just like I can't I
don't feel like I can make decisions
anymore and I really think that having
the concentration to focus for those 40
minutes makes it way easier for me to
focus in the 25 minutes you know like uh
it's I you know I don't really know if
that's science or not but I definitely
think that if I can stay focused for 40
minutes 25 minutes will feel like
nothing so I really like really push
myself there